[Music]
hey guys welcome to their instalments of
Harry Potter theory in this video we
could be discussing the Prisoner of
Azkaban the Marauders and Newt Scamander
now we know Newt Scamander as a lovable
main character of the new fantastic
beasts films Newt is a famed Magister
ologist and the author of fantastic
beasts and where to find them a book
outlining the study of magical creatures
the book has been described by Albus
Dumbledore as follows
newts masterpiece had been an improved
textbook at Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry
ever since publication and must take a
substantial amount of credit for
students consistently high results and
care of magical creatures examinations
yet it is not a book to be confined to
the classroom no visiting household is
complete without a copy of fantastic
beasts well-thumbed by the generations
who have rifled through its pages in
search of the best way to rid the lawn
of or clumps interpret the mournful
cries of the augury or cure their pet
puff skin after drinking out of the
toilet newt himself once described his
profession as follows I have visited
layers and burrows and nests across five
continents observed the curious habits
of magical beasts in a hundred countries
witness their powers gained their trust
and on occasion beaten them off with my
traveling kettle we get to know newt
quite well in the new fantastic beasts
films and there are many films still in
the way however one thing I always found
interesting was that newt scamander
appeared on the marauders map in the
Prisoner of Azkaban and this was way
before we saw him on screen in fantastic
beasts so what was new to doing on the
map after all newt was expelled from
Hogwarts long before Harriet was even
born
hidden the school from 1908 to 1913 the
marauders map is described as follows
the magic used in the maps creation is
advanced and impressive it includes a
monk ulis charm enabling the possessor
of the map to track the movements of
every person in the castle and it was
also enchanted to forever repel
as insultingly as possible the curiosity
of the nemesis severus snape with all of
that in mind I want to explore a couple
of popular fan theories the white is
that newt was actually on the map and
I'll give you my thoughts on both of
them after I've briefly introduced them
theory number one is that newt was
visiting Dumbledore Newt and Amador were
very close friends later in life and
Dumbledore even once taught Newt at the
time that Newt was expelled from
Hogwarts
Dumbledore was neutered professor and
tried vehemently to stop him from being
expelled did quite a deep friendship so
it makes sense the Nutri go to visit an
old friend his book was even part of the
hogwarts curriculum the theory number
two is that Newt was on the Hogwarts
grounds to help save Buckbeak one of the
key events of the Prisoner of Azkaban
was the execution Buckbeak the
Hippogriff it's completely reasonable to
expect the new to take a special
interest in puck beak Newt is a lover of
all animals and bug bigs unfair
sentenced to death would draw his
attention additionally newts mother was
a breeder of hypocrites so it would make
perfect sense that he would be
interested in this situation Newt
devoted his life to magical creatures so
it only makes sense that he would show
up and tried to stop the execution if
possible my own third theory was that
Newt was at Hogwarts to visit his
grandson Rolf Scamander Rolf was just a
year younger than Harry and attended
Hogwarts at the same time as the trio in
adulthood Rolf would actually go on to
marry during a Lovegood but the main
problem with all of these theories is
that they assumed that newt was still
alive some sources state that newt only
lived into the year 1991 or 1992 and
though he lived a hearty and full life
this would mean that he was already dead
by the Talmud Harry got his hands on the
marauders map if Newt was in fact dead
and my only explanation for him showing
up on the map was that he turned into a
ghost in the films there are several
instances in which ghosts show up on the
map so it makes perfect sense those who
decide to return to the mortal world as
a ghost do so because they have
unfinished business
this prevents them from moving on to the
next dimension in newts case if it
became a ghost upon death I would expect
that it was because he had unfinished
business of some sort perhaps still
searching for more creatures or in the
middle of researching a particular
creature
he was so devoted to his work that I can
really see him lingering around to see
it through if that isn't the case then
it must have really just been a little
easter egg that gave us a sense of what
was to come in the fantastic beasts
films and that's it for this video
what are your theories for why Newt
Scamander showed up on the warders map
in the Prisoner of Azkaban let us know
in the comments section below until next
time
your or was it Harry
[Music]